I gave a similar talk last year and this
talk is going to to kind of extend on
that because the talk is one hour I'm
going to separate it kind of in two
parts and initially it was in two parts
to begin with but right now it's that
the parts I'm going to do and let's see
the first part is I'm going to use this
mind map because in this kind of
comparison it's a little bit too chaotic
to switch between to do it only in one
only same presentation in I and only
presentation in in America so in the
first call for now I'm going to
summarize some of the key points in the
last year's presentation we are going to
look into simple functionalities which
are missing in Mathematica from my
perspective but they're present in are I
think an important part is to discuss
graphics how well do you see this and
yeah I think is what I would like to
give one illustrative example about the
differences hopefully if I have time in
this Cal for now I'll make the responses
I'll start some of the responses to
observe Asians I have seen in the talks
this year obviously about kids being a
lengthy list so but basically the first
the first four branches here hopefully
we will do in the first Cal for now and
you can attend another meeting
Vasia ways a github repository with this
comparison it's called Mathematica
versus ah unfortunately github is down
so during lunch time I was informed but
this is the case so if I click say this
it's basically nothing's happening so
anyway I do have pre-loaded some of this
some of these notebooks here so in in
principle you know
I'm not going to do this in principle
when you you can go to the github page
ma America versus R and it actually it
has an opening page and a nice breakdown
of the difference of the different
functionalities there and let me be a
little bit more specific like you'll be
able to see I hope something like this
[Music]
and so this they there's a table in this
in the github in the github repository
which actually says what exactly what
exactly is the breakdown envisioned of
the different functionalities to be
compared in between muffin America and
our projects so here are example some
example in this table you can see some
example projects like we are going to
look into this handwritten digits
classification by matrix factorization
and you can see what what what is saying
classification it is data ingestion
it's about images it uses latent
semantic analysis matrix factorization
and it's using parallel computations so
you can see this in the first row and
it's similarly for for the other
projects alright so so this like as I
said it's a good idea to kind of to
summarize what was discussed last year
on this topic and I'm going to it it
should be somewhere here you hope so
right so this is from last year 2015
Mathematica and are very come from the
same family with descendants of the Lisp
were very similar we're both universal
languages we're going to see mostly here
applications in statistics and
predictions and classification and so
forth but you can do other other stuff
with same with Mathematica Mathematica
is certainly more diversified into into
you know doing different stuff not so
specialized design in doing statistics
well very geologists are quite different
eyes a functional language obviously but
it's also with lazy evaluation and it's
based on objects I mean Mathematica also
has objects but not in such an explicit
way at least in my opinion
the data structures in a very different
it does help to have taken at least one
you know one course or two in statistics
in order to understand why I is doing
things in this way
it's basically following the mindset of
statisticians I in my previous talk just
this in this conference I stated what
I'm suspicious of substitutions I'm even
more suspicious after starting to use so
here's all the features of a designed by
committee in a bad way we're like 20
institutions who designed it most of the
features work most of the time but just
not good and now America is made by you
know by physicist and a computer
scientist and you know mainly by Stephen
who is a physicist and Stephen is
curating Mathematica as a language so
basically it's much more consistent we
are very often after you learn certain
rule or you think you got it there's
some exceptions which actually it's you
know you you need to learn the
exceptions of the general rule this I
find very frustrating
the only excusing excuse for our to be
like this is what it has been designed
3040 years ago long time ago and that's
why for example you have these short
names in the in the functions and so
forth so it has certain legacy which
okay I mean it
be accepted to a point it could have
been improved yes
it is very important to to learn about
data frames let me see here
it data frame is the major is the major
data structuring enough it's not the
most fundamental one but it is the cent
central one in many ways so you need to
know how to manipulate data frames
produce data frames query one and so
forth the granularity in eyes to a
vector so there is no scholars so the
the finest granularity you have in our
is a list of number or list of whatever
list of objects of the same time this
not necessarily not necessarily bad not
necessary good I understand why you've
done it as I said if you take the
statistical mindset you're like yeah we
don't use you don't use colors we use
all the vectors and tables and whatnot
all right
so lists and vectors they can take named
elements so in some sense they are very
similar to mathematical associations a
relatively new data structure is the
sparse matrix with so a doesn't have
sparse arrays it has parse matrices this
is really nice the sparse matrix
functionality is really nice there's
some new data structures like data table
and I don't know data table is probably
going to replace data frame it is a
little bit it is very state reduction of
data table into R it is very analogous
to introduction of data set in
Mathematica it's kind of like it's kind
of the same but also kind of different
and it does it does make our
practitioners to use this kind of data
in a different way not so much like
before with data frames a central a
central object is another object is
formulas will see probably some
applications of formulas in a sense if
you want to become intermediate a user
you need to use formulas factors
extremely annoying I don't I try to
avoid them as much as possible this is
again the statistical thinking
any-anything which is not a number we're
going to convert to integer this is what
factors are doing where some there is
sir all very interesting bugs but can be
produced in this way as I said avoid
using it the only reason I have not
specified in my options startup options
of factors never to be used is because
when I give code to some other people
they're not going to have this option
set so in a sense I wouldn't know but
you know what is happening conve side so
all right this enough with this I'm the
good features about our I headed
somewhere here we are certain unbeatable
features it's like almost impossible to
compete and so great idea support like
us to John is impressive product Emacs
peak statistics is a very old program
it's very nice IntelliJ IDEA which many
people use I do it I use it I use it
from of America for Java far not so much
but yeah it has supported somebody wrote
a plug-in for IntelliJ one of the best
features of is the package system so
with the package system you can you have
access to lots of packages this is just
a package system itself now ya think is
the actual packages if you need
something and you know we wondering how
to get your hands on it somebody wrote a
package for it you know probably and you
can find it and use it the when you
write documents which are important
thing it is important to be able to
integrate with other people other
systems and I actually does great job
its documentation integration with logic
markdown in HTML is really great you can
you can use it in in several ways we
also utilize an open-source product
program called panda panda allows you to
convert from different formats
you know in a reliable way something
very similar to the dynamic features of
Mathematica is shiny the shiny library
so this actually it's even in some sense
better and also I'll show why it is
still under active development so he
hasn't reached the maturity of the
dynamic functionality cinema of America
but you do have interactive interfaces
in you know and this can be very very
useful alright so this was this was what
was last year and you know I'll probably
expended a spanner too much on it but
you know it is important to mention this
so back to this mind map so so the
simple functionalities which I think we
should have in our Mathematica should
have but doesn't and we have equivalent
in enough and I'm going to show some
like for example and this is here one
example of this is a markdown a markdown
notebook this is not officially released
yet but I asked to do and what you see
is a studio it's a front-end tois it
does support notebooks format which is
in the markdown based on markdown so
here I hear from I'm loading some some
data and I'm making this command summary
so so this this summary command is going
to tell me what this empty cars is you
know it's having these columns mpg
cylinders whatever horsepower and they
have this values and so forth so I can
also go further and dry you know with
this command draw these cross
correlations between the different
variables so in some cases we can see we
have some correlation to etc so in
mathematical ways no I mean this command
like pairs and summary there are no
commands like that
and summary is probably one of the most
used commands in our and it's like it's
extremely useful to summarize the data
in one way or the other so the
corresponding commands in Mathematica
would be something like this and let me
position to knit so let me zoom here I'm
not going to use the empty cars example
I'm going to use the Titanic data
because well familiar with so basically
this lots of Titanic data you can see
with this command record summary I have
computed the summary this is something I
implemented this record summary it
basically gives me that the summary of
the summary of the data there and I have
another another command which I can call
this variable variable dependence grid
which can give me some some kind of
summarization of what what what's going
on in this data so like what is what is
similar to another think is cross
tabulation again in let me say like it's
very natural when you have this kind of
records of data right table some kind of
data table to to kind of want we want to
know how many what are the
co-occurrences between you know say how
many females have been in the first
class how many males have been the first
pass and so forth so this this here this
this is a generalization on cross
tabulate it's cross tens rate it works
actually in higher dimensions and this
is something I is doing when I mentioned
this formula object this is basically
what is happening you can specify the
column names here from Titanic passenger
class passenger age passenger sex and
survival so basically you can say look I
want to see the counts of you know of
this contingency values of these columns
and so if you do that you know sorry I
should have typed matrix form I mean you
can see you can see the breakdown of of
the different the different groups and
this is another example here which is
instead of using counts you can use you
can use the last column like you can see
in the summer here the passenger age is
not a categorical variable it is
Numerical so basically instead of doing
the just counting which I did say here
in cross in Cross tablet I can actually
add the edges so this is basically the
the summary age of the people in the
different different classes so alright I
mean this is this is something again you
know like this is something in obviously
very useful it's even if you just know
classifiers and etc I saw several
examples here people from the machine
learning group in North America with
basically they need to kind of do it
manually this here on it's a mosaic plot
a mosaic plot in green chain also like
several libraries but do mosaic plots
you know this here gives you a breakdown
I mean this is a visual breakdown of the
information we saw above so you can see
what we're different you know different
classes like different mean we start
from the from the passenger class then
we see you know the breakdown in male
and female and then in the survival this
tables here they did give you they give
you the conditional probabilities for
each of those so this is something
already now it doesn't look as pretty
doesn't look as functional but just has
been there for quite a while and people
use it quite often this is not in
Mathematica as I said I find it very
useful especially if you explore a new
data you know it's something to do all
right so our graphics well that I didn't
expand on this that free graphic systems
web based system lattice and ggplot
actually ggplot2 and base so this this
is one of the more frustrating things
for me I cannot use one of these graphic
systems to when I work with are I need
to basically know all three of them to
some degree in order to do practical to
solve practical problems
and ggplot is very nice it's written by
one of the most active contributors in
the our community he also works for he's
a senior scientist senior developer in a
studio
I know about lots of people in the
graphics department in in involved from
aware of the designs behind ggplot and
and they should the base one is very old
I mean it's I mostly because it's very
quick to use that's why I use it but in
general I don't like it watches is based
on a system called trellis this system
is long 34 years ago if you know I mean
you'll probably see some examples again
I'm really in the workflow in arm you
don't have such direct manipulation as
in Mathematica of the graphics objects
so you need to actually manipulate your
data frames in certain ways and then
after you may have manipulated your data
frames in certain ways you can feed them
to the plotting functions this sounds
abstract but I'm going to show it in the
illustrative example which of the
differences which is the next branch
here to make to make something to make a
good example of what something really
hard doing in our hopefully this is
going to work yes
alright so this is a blog post I did
like probably a month ago to assume we
want to we have um you have some data
like this and you want to remove this
the free data you want to remove out
laughs and so actually you can see this
is the full data but if you zoom to it
you know it's very clearly some outliers
what I do is I'm basically making some
envelopes around this data using it's a
it's basically the data I'm going and
finding the center of the data and I'm
rotating it in different angles and I'm
finding you know I'm finding basically
98% which which plane divides the points
to 90 88% below and above so if I do
this
efficiently many directions I'm going to
produce some kind of I can produce some
kind of surface envelope like this now
what is nice about it is but you can
actually this function quantile envelope
region it is used it is using region
member it is using the region functions
it's actually fairly efficient fairly
quick to do and here the actual outliers
the reason I'm showing this example is
what yeah this is very relevant to only
do data analysis in text cetera are
doesn't have 3d graphics they all live
in this 2d world
so you know and it's very bleak in my
opinion but whatever so this using using
the 3d graphics and having final final
access to the graphics primitives in
many ways in my opinion is it's really
useful all right so the the example I
was talking about of the differences and
this one I'm going to extract it here so
now let me see you know as far as I know
github is not it's not accessible so I'm
not going to do to do with it so we're
going to
right well let me see something here is
it going to to work out okay good all
right so so here I actually we have seen
enough especially you know for time
series data you might have seen enough
several talks of how we are accessing
time series data data for weather
weather time series this one of the
things we far like and do I have chosen
this example is being illustrate if you
need to there's no standard package for
getting this kind of data we need to
basically get this package weather data
which is well reputed well known is
maintained by one person he commits you
know reliably on on on github but
basically this is it
after after that you need to yeah we
need to kind of download this package to
read the manual how to use it it's you
cannot just specify say Atlanta Georgia
which is what I want you need to
actually find the stations in Atlanta
Georgia and then from the stations in
Atlanta Georgia to actually get the the
weather data in order to use the ggplot
which I'm going to show later it
recommends with it as I said you need to
be able to reshape your data into
particular form which is used by the
graphics that's why if you plot to you
need to use reshape to it's like
impossible not use it otherwise I'm a
big fan of quantile regression and this
is this package here can towel rack it's
one of the most important contributors
in control regression we're going to see
but it's a very different philosophy
when you use this kind of fittings with
with with our so here basically we're
just reading the reading the data I mean
from whatever I basically found found
the station I also realized but I cannot
exactly query for for range of dates
which exceed one year so you need to
kind of actually make this kind of loop
which kind of goes through the years and
so forth so finally at some
point we do get we do get the we get we
do get the data and then we we can
produce this kind of time series plot so
when I'm fitting the quantiles I am I'm
using this package but you see this is
the formula I'm talking about and this
is the RQ I mean what I said like you
use okay iq is for you know regression
quantiles
actually that's a widely well the known
name but just looking at IQ of course
you cannot guess it and this comes from
the from the times in which you know
people have been naming making small
commands in when you deal with computer
computers and programming languages the
the infix operator you see here it's
actually a matrix multiplication this is
this is what is happening if you stay
for the second part of the talk I'll be
talking more about in fixed operations
and how you can define and redefine
operators you know it's very similar to
what we do in Mathematica it is actually
quite nice in a sense the what we see
here the do call parts in which I need
to combine all these curves in order to
to plot them into and put them into a
data frame the do call part is actually
it's actually apply so I'm applying this
function see bind on these curves and
then we get concatenated basically the
curves they are not curves we're just
were just vectors at this point the as I
said just line with X multiplying fit
coefficients it's a you know it's a
matrix vector multiplication so we
produce yeah we we have basically
produced vectors corresponding to the
quantile curves and now we want to put
them together as columns in a table and
this table is called data frame and then
with this data frame we are going to be
plotting stuff and so in order to plot
it and have this kind of colorful plots
actually need to use ggplot and some
melt function and whatnot
and then produce this pot if you know I
mean it's pretty dramatic if you have
done it a few times just some people
claim it becomes automatic I don't think
so
but whatever you can see here but again
there's some kind of variables you can
specify which variables have been used
in what way why is this happening and so
forth this is the ggplot commands which
a set is very nice we are basically
saying we are going to work on this data
frame we are going to be making lines
and this lines the x axis is going to be
dates the y axis is going to be
temperatures and then we make making
some other lines with the featured
quantiles
the first one here comes from from the
time series and finally we are going to
have a point part which is for the
outliers the points in red so I mean
again now it might seem quiet for rain
right now but actually it is quite
interpretable it's quite it's quite nice
it's close to Russia quite nicely if you
have seen done it couple of times you
actually can maintain this kind of code
you know all right so what was
interesting for me is but from here when
I have this kind of quantiles if I
specify a time a time point in time like
say this white line here
I would like to reconstruct watches that
watches the PDF and the CDF at this
point and this is you can see this one
of the reasons to use quantile
regression the signal is very
heteroskedastic this means what let's
look at it in the original form here the
variance is depending Condor on time so
you can see what during the summer the
temperature is much more you know it
gets much smaller variance and during
the winter Atlantis is a southern state
there is no winter like in shrimp
actually whatever but it's not as cotton
not as quarters it doesn't get usual as
kotas here but you do have this wide
variation you don't know we don't know
if from the day before you cannot
exactly predict what is going to the to
be in or the temperature in the next day
so
of this it might be an important
obviously from any kind of perspective
like machine learning statistical data
mining whatever you know you might want
to be able to reconstruct the PDF and
CDF at different time points and so so
this is what is happening here in this
example and in order to do that I need
to use some function approximate this
didn't work actually that well basically
don't have a reliable interpolate
function in our you know avais something
but you cannot use it in the same way
you use it in Mathematica you need to do
some kind of manual stuff and you see
this is what I'm doing with this PDF
estimate function or whatever if you
decide to use spline functions then yes
you can integrate it sorry you can
differentiate it it's going to be smooth
but actually doesn't fit the the CDF and
the PDF doesn't look as nicely all as
informative if you use linear linear
interpolation so this here can be
completely compared with let me see here
I did started before and it started with
with this time series part here so if
you if you see the mathematical part
hopefully we can or not
well well this I'm waiting for this to
load we're going to look into what I
showed you earlier with this opening
page with some statement here about what
this project doing the projects
organized the in general the mission
statement behind this this repository is
to is to collect simple but not trivial
not trivial projects of doing different
machine learning and statistical tasks
like something like this with the
quantile regression it's like I mean it
has been also for a question for me if I
want to do all this part which I know
how to do in Mathematica all this how I
do it you know so the this is not
exactly a rosetta stone
type of you know collection of commands
between muff America and ah you need to
know fair amount of Mathematica or fair
amount of ah at least but you can also
like see how what is the correspondence
I usually keep like at least 95
correspondence between the codes
sometimes it just doesn't make any sense
to keep hundred percent correspondence
because the languages are different I
mean but the logic between between the
develop the exposition is kind of the
same and let me see this if this with
markup EGF non-agent well I mean it's
it's not a big deal I guess I can go to
projects I can go to to the time series
with quantile regression and show you
this file which if you look at this file
it's it's basically following as I said
it's following exactly and more or less
the same the same points and you know
you fit the quantiles and you make the
extractions of the PDS and sit yes but
you can in a sense by side by side you
can actually look at this coach and see
what is going on alright so this was the
let me see in my mind map I wanted to
make a couple of points here so you see
since I assume you know you know
Mathematica to a twister point you and
you're less familiar with ah I would
like to point out several things it is
really important to be able to work with
data frames to be able to create
manipulate and reshape and whatnot
data frames there is no way around it so
to speak you need to master it and the
general workflow in arm is very often
other set is very statistically
motivated lexis additions like to use
design matrices and so forth so yeah
this is what was happening for this
quantile regression I didn't actually
produce like in Mathematica what I'll do
I'll use the b-spline basis which are
just functions and I'll use some weights
and I discovered do the linear
programming et cetera my Mathematica
implement a
just takes the notes and takes the the
notes on which this b-spline basis is
going to be in now you actually need to
provide the design matrix for the best
points and this is something we consider
normal where basically it is such an
idiom for I mean theoretical idiom for
the statisticians but you're going
through it and so the last points which
I already mentioned you need to gather
your functionalities meaning you need to
figure out which packages you're going
to use there are some packages which are
more maintains very used more often and
so forth it's not even like in
mathematical more or less you can fairly
well query the help system and you know
find how to you know how to do say you
know weather weather forecasting oh you
know weather data retrieval and whatnot
you might have several options in now
which can provide very different outputs
from what you're doing
and you had at the mercy of the
developer but they have they have done
it you know they have documented how to
do that usually this is enforced by the
by the repository for submitting
packages you're supposed to write a
vignette which basically is a use case
type of document which tells you how to
use whatever and I think in this
particular in this particular particular
document which I've been looking at we
looked at visa Basel they should be they
should be a link to the vignette by
Roger Quaker which I hope it's working I
mean this is basically he explains here
how to use how to use quantile quantile
regression you know and he has like
different use cases basically this is
what I I mean I read a register Clemente
this is how I learned how to use this
contract package and so forth right okay
well and so I mean I went over for this
Cal for now which I promised I'll do my
but this is basically the first part
part of the
exposition I was I was I wanted to do it
is very interesting to look at some of
the functionalities which parallel the
functionalities we see we saw in earlier
in the conference or functionality which
was actually promised like spark for
example now let's look at the first two
actually the ascription spark I'm
talking about this branch here now so
this a scripts we have been around
forever you can use you can use
scripting you know it's fairly
straightforward you just say a script
whatever our program and it's going to
be executed I use it very fairly often
and it is indispensable to communicate
ideas especially with customers or
engineers like very often I'll do
interactive interfaces which would kind
of if I want everyone to get on board
engineers and stakeholders I'll do that
actually just just to abstract I let's I
kind of mention something like that form
when we are discussing the brain
networks from time series so let me
actually go to let me show you one of
these how it how it is done so here I
have this so basically I have a session
this is this is an hour session and I
have this this file like a code file you
know which basically loads the loads the
libraries loads the session which was
saved and as that that does some
initialization and then it calls the
dynamic interface what is happening is
I'm going to do a script on this so this
is going to initialize the whole thing
and it's going to produce a new arel
this URL is produced by the library
shiny and I'm going to show it here this
is basically running local
my computer this is an interface to a
dynamic interface not sure how well it
looks like but if you don't believe me
actually I mean you can believe me but
basically this is actually a bit
perjured graph it's one of the questions
I had the presenter with the new with
the brain networks and so you can see
what I have two types of nodes movies
and actors and if I for example move to
this action adventure drama and you know
in tweak some of the parameters here I'm
going to hear slightly different
recommendations now Star Trek becomes
the most important movie and you know
William Shatner becomes the most
important actor and so forth and you can
look at different you know different
parts of of how it how it looks like you
know how things look like why for
example the Pareto distribution of the
ranks and so forth as I said I can
actually package this into one zip file
upload it to say Google Drive whatever
give it to customers engineers we can
have a interactively kind of experiment
with the ideas I'm proposing not use
much you know statistical language
hand-waving
and then you know after everyone agrees
or not with what we are doing you know
we proceed doing it it is indispensable
it's I don't I mean Mathematica has
similar promise of doing things you know
you can deploy on the web and stuff like
word you can use CGF I have tried all
that with is just it's really it's
really when it worked with Gela
solutions they were not so good all
right so spark on I do have a code for
spark are actually which I would like to
share but let me see in my document here
again this might be all right this
actually this is very nice like in
saying some interviews or job interview
so we might ask me know like oh he will
Scott do post parking like you know this
question was important five years ago
when you know when it required
significant software engineering skills
to be
you know to find the minimum over some
kind of large database no you know like
right now we just fire up very quickly
actually you can it's fairly streamlined
many of these services you can if you
know ah you just instantiate in stomach
make an instance with say spark
connecting to our and the our engine
works it intimately with the
corresponding Java components of the
spark framework we're not exactly Java
spark is written in in in Scala but it
is a java virtual machine based type of
solution so basically whatever but you
you can you can actually do lots of
stuff in in this way we've aren't and
spark vision a solution called h2o I'm
not sure I don't think this waste time
to discuss it but it's equally strong
equally good what I would like to
mention is because either lazy
evaluation language this actually fits
fairly well the whole workflow and maybe
I should be a little bit you know less
hand waving and more shrink examples the
whole workflow of doing things with with
spark actually make more we kind of
makes sense with with spark a so let me
do this I guess so
I mean you can see here but I have been
I loaded the spark spark library after
the spark library has been spark or a
library he has been loaded
I have some separate drive for data
which I don't want to keep on my lap on
my laptop so basically I'm telling spark
right now this read Jason this SQL
context was created up here with Miss
Parker so this SQL context is basically
triggering some point of the spark site
to ingest data and I'm saying would read
this read this JSON file and now when I
have this JSON file read across the
different processors and etc I can
actually make certain commands like this
so these commands were not executed
immediately you actually need to use
this command collect so basically until
this point here so I start with a
certain data frame this data frame which
I prepared earlier
I took some representative you can see
what I have really big data so I took a
very small sample of it hopefully sir
presentative but that's actually beside
the point right now so I'm grouping
grouping the points in this sample and
then I'm making the summarization then
when I say the command collect this
triggers the the query across all the
process and gives the information back
to back to you fairly trivial if you
think about it obviously used in
MapReduce Hadoop is just one commenting
in Mathematica called parallel combine
that's all this now I mean you can also
sit in SQL SQL banker functional
language when you have group by having
you know this kind of like when you have
like you know select you know whatever
from whatever table then you have group
by and where it's this is what is
happening here it's just the
functionality is being implemented in a
different way across this SPARC
architecture and so forth using ah so
ice intimately connected on each of the
spark notes with the whatever spark code
counterpart and this is happening there
okay I mean it case Alden sake has been
there for well maybe for at least 2-3
years
it is very streamlined at this point as
I say you know it's almost it's very
fairly quick or fairly easy to to use it
if I go back to mine mind map I do
actually have couple of Link's here like
visa I mean if you want to learn more
about it out but going to basically this
mind map has lots of links published or
you can actually look at the guide here
and kind of see you can see more how you
can use parka
alright so I mean I think I hey I'm in
missions enough about this
so we from since all of our our
accounting said
he was kind of he mentioned something
about using dynamic interfaces over
Piggy's yeah I assume she is right but
me actually this is kind of it's not
something to do in our 10 minutes all
right it's not something you do in our
often but you actually yeah okay so I'm
going to skip this example but basically
you can is this something I actually
demonstrated last year you have an
interactive interface for for what what
is happening I would actually want to
show you the geo mapping feature and
this kind of illustrates certain certain
things let me see here so I'm going to
to quit this session this is actually
another thing which is relatively new in
our studio you can open multiple
sessions for different for different
projects so I'm going to open this Yelp
API project and so presumably this will
block quickly enough and so if I run
this basically I I need to have some
absorb you need to have like the Web API
Yelp API keys you need to setup the
security and stuff like that
so what happened here let's see actually
I mean this might be producing some
interesting map you know for those from
the Miami area you know yeah well this
Miami Beach and in this particular
project were interested in bus in Miami
Beach because this is actually what
people are doing it's only there so yeah
they're basically mapped here again you
know like all right fine I mean whatever
my point is definitely not as fancy as
good as what's in Mathematica not as
consistent in a sense you need to go for
quite a lot of Hoops to do that you need
to figure out how to parse the data from
Yelp and so forth you I cannot do this
by myself somebody
actually has been done this work but to
some extent this is the other advantage
of our of America suffers of something
called the Lisp curse and I really hope
I can actually find this well it's a
fairly old article which basically says
look I mean because this is so
consistent and so if you're bright
enough you can go so far with it if
they're basically just not much
documentation about it I mean there's no
people who use this they don't need much
help they can actually do lots of stuff
of you know by themselves
now this is something similar to with
with with Mathematica I mean yeah we
obviously discuss things in status
change X etc but ah has been focus beam
always difficult to do stuff enough so
basically there are lots of help I mean
if you have any kind of question you
know about how to do something cuivre
already has been answered so invariably
you know so and so basically this is
this is what was happening with this
particular you know like when I was
doing quickly open to etc yeah I mean it
was kind of about again gathering the
data gathering the access figuring out
what's going on you need to be in
command of it but I already read
somebody you know like what somebody
wrote about this kind of things how to
how to deal with it I do here for a
little bit
let me see actually and don't say let me
see here maybe you can make chat bots
with AH
nobody else does it probably except me
but you can actually program you can do
functional parsers and text cetera with
ah this unfortunately because gift-wrap
is down I cannot I cannot show you this
but basically this function I have
written a bunch of functional parcels in
in in functionalities in Mathematica
which hopefully I
and demonstrates quickly enough within
five minutes yeah so basically with this
tool dysfunctional parcels tool you can
create relatively easily domain-specific
languages and so here you can see like
some language about food-loving how you
specify it in the extended Baku snore
forum and you can actually you know do
something like you can produce some kind
of conversational engine type
functionality with it basically this
natural language has been parsed to this
mathematical expression and now you need
to provide hooks for love food and love
type and whatnot and then produce you
know produce the actual result and you
see this is actually what is happening
here this implementation here in
Mathematica justice provides
implementations for love objects love
calories and when I call block for love
food to be with love food calories and
love objects to be love objects calories
basically what what you see here it's
being converted into this this this
dialogue expression so so this actually
as I said this can be done in a in a
Mathematica let me sorry enough and I'm
going to hopefully demonstrate this
within the next four minutes which I
don't see easily happening just a moment
I'll I'll do this fairly quickly yeah
let's see
so basically this language is very
similar it's a different type of grammar
but basically if I if I let me if I run
this code it should ok I have written
the parsers
to to a large degree you can see what
say this stream here which is from this
string if we if you look at what is here
this is basically character by character
breakdown of this and so now at this
point I mean I can sorry I can do
because this is a becaus node form of
the grammar I can parse I can run this
parser and basically all the rules have
been parsed so now I need to have the
automatic generation of the parsers
because I passed the grammar so this is
basically I'm very close to implementing
casino functionality now to make
conversational engines I was doing
conversational engines three years ago
for Panasonic automotive systems America
it's a really lots of fun it is
definitely doable now I'm using
something called monadic parsers if you
look further into this into these codes
in the links I have provided you'll see
what actually and this is how I'll
finish this talk you'll see what
actually can you can program the infix
operators I have some much longer I have
just descriptive names like mathematical
like mathematical style descriptive
names of parsers and parser combiners
and this actually here you know makes
these combinations and then you know I
have shorter names and so forth and
right so basically the parsing is being
done well thank you for your attention
you know I hope this was a useful
presentation
you